first for you sholo
one of my favorite scenes of the entire
season was miguel's conversation with
daniel and correct me if i'm wrong but i
believe that's the first
real conversation that you you actually
got to have so
having seen ralph too much do so much
other work on the show
what expectations did you have going
into that scene working with him and how
might he have surprised you you know i
think there was like the run-on joke was
like ah it took us three seasons to
kind of talk to each other when i feel
like a lot of our story lines intertwine
obviously
johnny is the glue between the the two
of us uh i think
one of my and i you know i've mentioned
this before but one of my favorite
moments in season one is getting to sit
down with johnny and hear his side of
what happened during karate kid one
so getting to hear you know as a
character getting to hear the other side
of that
and seeing like oh dang so that's what
happened and then
you know going through the motions in
that regard was was
super super fun i think you know getting
to work with ralph
and billy they both have very different
styles of
like how they kind of run because i
guess when when both of them are on set
they're not
really running the set necessarily but
they definitely have this sense of
energy around them that
kind of helps everyone move along and i
think both of them
are are very different in the way that
they kind of get prepared and and get
ready for scenes and whatnot but
you know regardless it was super it was
super fun to film
uh with with ralph he's uh he's a pretty
big jokester but
in my heart it's always gonna be uh you
know uh team johnny
oh man i have so many follow-ups but
limited time here and i can't not ask
about the
big and fight scene this time around and
specifically for you jacob one of my
absolute
favorite beats in that scene was finally
seeing hawk and dimitri fight side by
side
on set while you're doing it is it as
cathartic and
exciting for you and gianni as it is for
us as viewers
so that was like the last thing that we
one of the last things that we ended up
doing
was that uh where we i run down the
corridor
and you know jump off of him and kick
and
you know we start doing our bit and so
the whole day we were like all right
like we had the choreography memorized
we're good to go and like as the energy
the water's going you know
we're all feeling it and then we get to
that moment we're like dude
like this is it like let's freaking do
it you know and gianni
was so stoked because he you know
because the first season he didn't get
to do uh
any stunts in any fights and he came he
was like
i'm so excited to do a fight with you
this is gonna be great you know
uh but yeah in total we we totally feel
the same way you know byron
binary brothers for life um but uh yeah
it was great i had a blast doing that
that final spin we both do those the
little tornado kicks it's
it was really really fun hands down one
of the best payoffs in the season i love
it
so i don't even know if you have an
answer for this yet jacob or if you know
anything about future seasons but it's
something that's kind of gotten stuck on
my mind now
do you think that eli can maintain the
hawk
look and identity while trying to be a
better person
than what he was at cobra kai or is that
identity
too tied to that you know
i think uh a lot of soul searching has
to be done for him to be able to find
that
uh to find that answer in all honesty i
think
right now you know even at the end of
season three
i i don't know if he would be able to
handle
and vice versa i don't know if he would
be able to handle having the hawk
mentality while
you know looking like eli or you know
being sort of the good guy
while you know having the mohawk because
i think
right now they're so separated um and i
think that's something that would be
really fun to explore as you know kind
of merging those two
because you know for the whole entire
time it kind of has been like
eli and hawk and they're two very
different people well i mean they're
still the same person but um i think you
should start riding
yeah yeah yeah if only one day
i think uh i think your head trio over
there is doing quite a good job though
oh yeah they're awesome huge
congratulations on the new uh
season you guys thank you so much for
your time today yeah